we very appreciate for our friends
for great britain boris johnson
announced and also give the support uh
the united states uh some our friends
declared
support of ukraine declarate support of
our wishes to build european country uh
but sometime if we need the help between
declaration in the plantation uh huge
distance and that's why we need support
we need support in any way political
support economical support weapons
support we need the defensive weapon
defensive weapon because
modern weapons very important right now
and we ask about
the weapons we have to defend our
country and uh and very appreciate for
everyone who support in this moment
our
uh our ukraine are you getting enough
help from the germans
it's
uh
his joke
by the way i
[Music]
want to say thank you but it's
it's not enough
it's it's not really help what's a joke
to
instead the weapons defensive weapons we
receive 5 000 health
5000 helmets five thousand helmets and a
field hospital and they say that sends a
very clear signal we're on your side
the germans say that
germans have
to be
the germans have to decide in which side
if ukraine defend defend
our
independency
in territorial integrity or in the sight
of aggressors
germans political politicians have to
decide and you don't think they've
decided yet it's not clear to you
right now it's not clear answer